[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de vip
aujourd'hui je reçois jocelyne sauvard
qui est l'auteur d'un livre qui est
sorti n'y a pas très longtemps salle st
marcel un amour de proust aux éditions
du rocher
jocelyne sauvard bonjour bonjour merci
d'être sur notre plateau pour ce vip que
l'on va entièrement vous consacrez à
vous et à votre livre bien évidemment
alors vous avez plusieurs liens avec les
yvelines parce que vous m'avez dit que
fut un temps vous aviez animer des
ateliers d'écriture à saint quentin
voilà donc vous connaissez la région et
vous avez aussi vous parler
pardon de proust qui a souvent résider à
versailles
oui l'hôtel riviera roi voilà et notre
fameuse céleste albaret qui est
l'héroïne si je puis dire de votre livre
est là sont de e2 et austère il ya une
héroïne est un héros voit la céleste
albaret elle a terminé s'agit une fois
proust décédé à mon enfant a mûri comme
gardienne de la maison de maurice ravel
le belvédère sera là tout est dit alors
vous vous nous proposez donc ce livre
céleste et martèle un amour de proust
qui met en lumière un personnage
jusqu'ici pas très connu du grand public
on est d'accord
comment vous alors déjà vous êtes aussi
pardon écrivain journaliste critique
littéraire écrivains de pièces de
théâtre il qu'est-ce que j'oublie pièce
de théâtre j'ai écrit aussi des livres
pour la jeunesse beau colin sauce faire
le meilleur faut toujours faire la
meilleure maintenant en particulier pour
les jeunes des abolissant les iphone et
puis j'ai écrit des biographies lé voilà
les doit à mon personnage célèbre
massiwa nouvel iphone et charles de
gaulle jacques et bernadette oui comment
il s'appelle déjà ça danielle mitterrand
enfin bref les hauts degrés oui donc là
vous vous attaquez si je puis dire à un
écrivain comme comment vous est venue
cette idée
cool ce qui pour vous déjà rouge c'est
toute ma vie ma région
déjà parce que je le connais depuis très
longtemps je me souviens qu'en 6ème un
professeur de français
plaçons nous avait lu une page de marcel
proust je m'en souviens très bien
la lumière y soler ça m'avait beaucoup
plu et puis je les lui par moi même
parce qu'il était chez moi dans ma
famille sur une commode d'accord du côté
de chez swann je les lui j'ai beaucoup
aimé j'ai beaucoup ri j'ai réfléchi
beaucoup sur la jalousie et se soignent
très élégant qui me faisait penser à mon
frère est d'accord et puis deux ans plus
tard on m'a offert à l'ombre des jeunes
filles en fleurs alors comme on aimerait
en était une 17 ans donc j'ai
complètement plongé dans l'ombre des
jeunes filles en fleur et je n'en suis
jamais sorti en passant par les autres
volumes les études sur proust les
dossiers les écrits d éminents
spécialistes d'accord oui vous êtes
vraiment plonger totalement dans cet
univers alors à côté moi comment vous
est venue cette idée de décrire sur
céleste albaret jacky et est elle alors
céleste albaret c'est une jeune femme
qui venait de lozère auxillac et qui
étaient les qui a épousé odilon albaret
le chauffeur de taxi de marcel proust
qui le conduisait la nuit ici là en
normandie à paris et donc il a amené à
paris sa jeune femme elle s'est ennuyé
odilon on a parlé à marcel proust qui
lui a dit aux jeunes femmes sont amies
de sa mère il faut absolument l'occuper
si vous voulez si elle veut elle
pourrait faire la cour hier elle
porterait mais livrent à des écrivains
auxquels je l'envoie et des éditeurs
elle a accepté
et voilà les choses ont commencé comme
ça mais un mois plus tard c'est la
guerre 1914
odilon part au front elle est tout seul
et marcel proust lui propose de venir
habiter chez lui boulevard haussmann ce
qu'elles font et post qui ne peut pas
faire la guerre car il est asthmatique
d'année degré il est donc la forme et il
en est d'ailleurs un peu coupables ce
sont les gens comparent il se sent
malheureux - mais insiste sur ce qu'il
ne porte qu'un fer sur le front d'accord
alors comment est ce que vous avez
trouvé d'où tous ces matériaux
extrêmement riche que vous nous révéler
donc à travers cette histoire
incroyable lorsqu'à la fabo elle n'a pas
écrit finalement céleste alba non pas un
mot sur des cartes de voeux enfin oui
mais un journal comme d'ailleurs pour
lui avait recommandé de oui bien sûr ça
aurait été une idée formidable
donc voilà je me suis substituer un
petit peu oui et alors donc voilà elle
elle n'a jamais écrit effectivement elle
a lu la recherche
et moi j'ai lu la recherche dans les
coins puisque j'ai lu et relu les
volumes les esquisses les essais les le
courrier les milliers de lettres les
notes j'ai eu les grands spécialistes
comme jean yves tadié en train de
compagnon jérôme bastianelli jacqueline
bloch dano et c est vous l'avez trouvée
et est donc voilà m et c'est le me suis
pas arrêté là j'ai fondé uv sur le temps
retrouvé et en arrivant à la fac je
m'étais dit mais je n'ai rien à prendre
maintenant je ne savais rien et gérer
après tout mais à travers l'oeuvre de
pouce pardon vous avez trouvé la
présence de ce personnage de céleste
albaret tout et on est servi oui as à
son nom propre
il en parle il en parle à deux reprises
dans les jeunes filles en fleur il en
parle c'est une fiction la recherche
ce n'est pas marcelle sur le narrateur
mais parle de cette jeune femme qui est
qui a une très belle langue qu'ils
parlent un très bon français un peu
poétique qui qualifie sade génie
poétique de céleste carré oui et parce
qu elle lui disait des choses très drôle
comme en mai vous êtes comme un oiseau
tombé du nid dans votre lit et puis
voilà donc qui lui consacre quelques
lignes d'accord et alors elle elle a un
rôle primordial finalement pour lui
cette fin de vie on a l'impression
qu'ils sont sans elle ja il le dit sans
seles de je ne peux pas écrire ou une
faisant il le dit parce que ce sont un
argument de choc pour la convaincre
il le dit à son mari je devais écrire et
le sexe ça va la toucher au plus profond
parce qu'elle est extrêmement fatiguée
et puis surtout elle était un peu
jalouse de toutes les personnes les
princesses les les femmes du monde les
femmes de lettres qui entourait marcel
et elle lui avait dit mais
il faudrait quelqu'un de de plus
instruites que moi et dans le roman il
ya une jeune fille aussi un la
narratrice voilà il faudrait quelqu'un
comme ça et mensonges ou comme céleste
je peux passer de vous et comme il avait
servi l'argument chèque
évidemment elle est restée de toute
façon quand elle fait ailleurs et c'est
juste qu'elle avait envie d'être
rassurés c'est ce qu'elle avait envie
d'entendre
parce que tu es quand même une vie c'est
un couple improbable déjà il ya une
différence de classe sociale et
finalement ça ne se sent absolument pas
dit que vous dites vous même que proust
admirer met en avant les talents de
céleste est elle enfin c'est acquis un
peu magique finalement ils sont hors
dehors du temps et est donc l'un ne va
pas sans l'autre
concrètement comment est-ce qu'elle
l'aide à écrire elle ne l'est pas est
rien elles aident à vivre à l aide à
vivre l aide elle d'abord elle fait la
tâche primordiale c'est de faire le café
chez lou lamoriello de marcel proust
6h10 et le café du matin
c'est comme 6 heures du soir où j'ai
l'air du soir huit heures du soir sa
découpe juste deux secondes jocelyne
sauvard excuse moi c'est que cous de vie
la nuit
voilà donc se réveille à 17 18 heures
parce qu'il est insomniaque
donc il faut qu'ils prennent des
médicaments pour dormir et puis les pros
tard parce qu'il écrit les nuits ça et
puis la nuit sort il va des soirées
mondaines va à la chasse à la matière
pourront tout à fait ça pour ça ont
servi dans ses romans
voilà où s'il a déjà acquis tout ce
qu'il lui fallait il a besoin de
vérifier si le chapeau dorian de
guermantes qu'elle portait le 14 juillet
à 19h en allant au ritz était bien aux
violets donc concrètement vous nous
racontez ça et c'est vraiment
passionnant
lll l'assistant fait ce n'est pas sa
servante passe de gouvernante et c'est
son assistante voilà on dit gouvernante
a eu dit à ses amis
mama belles femmes de chama belles
créatures ou ou gouvernante mais en fait
c'est ce n'est pas sa gouvernante elle
et nal cerrato elle est présente elle et
elle ne fait pas la cuisine rien du tout
de du domaine domestique
simplement quand il est sorti
le soir elle est là r la chambre elle
arrange les papiers avec un soin
extraordinaire il s'est fait une
confiance totale parce que elle sait le
faire
elle sait qu'aucun petits maux mêmes
chiffres des deux sera jetée et voilà l
arrange les 22 serviettes de toilette du
cabinet de toilette et puis alors elle
me des draps propres tous les jours et
puis voilà ça c'est fait et ensuite elle
attend mais latente plaisir un délice
dans la rade clé il n'a pas de clé et
puis même s'il avait eu une
c'est l'habitude c'est l'habitude quand
il était jeune il disait madame est là à
la personne qui n'est vrai c'est-à-dire
félicite dans la réalité
françoise dans le roman et puis ensuite
seul et échanges sont allés chambre
nicolas copin et puis la céleste
elle est là elle l'attend elle ouvre
elle sourit tout de suite et elle essaie
soleil et sa lumière a complètement et
la diarrhée commence mais parce qu'il
lui dit seles nous n'allons pas rester
là sur nos jambes comme ça on n'est pas
bien dans l'encré venait dans ma chambre
est avérée elle entre dans le cocon
voilà et là il lui raconte sa soirée
c'est à dire qu'il ne la raconte pas il
la lui fait vivre imeem tous les
personnages
elle rit parce qu'il a un amour
extraordinaire des talents d'imitateur
incroyable et elle aussi
oui ça fait limite pour lui les
personnes qu'elle a par exemple au
téléphone mais j'y vois la lm il se
moque
oui oui oui mais 10,4
considéré au total est alors à quel
point elle a même dit un peu
l'internation le côté chanter de la
gamme inouïe de marcel proust
à tel point que la princesse toute chose
c'est à dire la lafam les pouces morand
de paul morand lui lui dis quelquefois
mais je croyais que c'était marcel as
voilà ouais c'est fou et alors donc il
fallait des donc jusqu'à la fin de sa
vie complètement
grâce à elle il va terminer son oeuvre
oui voilà elles réelles elle ne coupe
pas à meslay de cours
aussi à ramasser tous ces morceaux de
papier lui ces morts sont vérifiées et
puis surtout elle a l'idée de faire
parce que c'est très compliqué parce
qu'il ya la pile de cahiers ont molesté
noir il en a 75
et puis il ya aussi d'autres choses des
carnets des agendas des feuilles
volantes et donc lé garde bien elle les
arrange bien et quand les livres vont
être publiés les épreuves arrive et les
épreuves c'est toujours un moment
douloureux pour un écrivain corrigé faut
corriger ce que par exemple les
corrupteurs lui ajouter comme faute par
exemple le jeune andré breton
donc il est très fâché alors savoir par
un fou mais c'est qu'il est plus en plus
faible aussi physiquement cette eau
bénite bien sûr ils les mathématiques et
il a une telle énergie
il a une telle énergie une telle volonté
de finir l'oeuvre est donc voila voila
ca laquelle elle tient en vie jusqu'au
bout elle découpe des grandes feuilles
de papier parce qu'il était désolé du
chum en sortir seuls
alors elle découpe des grandes feuilles
de papier qu'elle colle ou kelkoo aux
manuscrits
elle en fait un accordéon si bien qu'il
n'a que le déroule dans le déroulé pour
lire et ajoutée unique siège note qu'à
lui facilite grandement le travail vous
voulez bien nous lire juste la première
phrase tu pèses ça c'est juste
magnifique ça résume très bien la vie de
ce couple incroyable cécélès qui parle
c'est à dire que oui par elle elle parle
tout seul quand elle est dans la cuisine
je laime je l'aimais et j'aimais cette
ville il m'avait contigent d'une façon
totale elle le dira toute sa vie elle
rayonnait dès qu'elle parlait de lui il
était en elle comme elle le dira une
amie longtemps après la mort de proust
céleste ne parler que de lui
elle vivait avec proust et continuera
jusqu'à la fin de ses jours voilà c'est
magnifique et après parce que la fin de
ses jours
ce sont
se passe à montfort l'amaury comme on
disait tout à l'heure mais bon elle
restera complètement des dauphins voué à
proust plutôt caravelle venez la voir
elle montrait bien sûr tous les objets
de ravel et évidemment les cahiers les
portes et le piano mais elle l arrivée à
parler de proust et il faut dire que
proust était aussi un admirateur de
ravel oui donc tout se tenait bon écoute
et justin se marre un grand merci je
trouve qu'on a beaucoup d'émotion et
lire ce livre le kit un peu triste parce
que bon on lâche un endroit complètement
calfeutrer les voudra côté que la
chambre étendue de liège
il ya une certaine lumière et que tout
va impulser la pandémie en dessous le
confiner sélection construit mais ils
ont dans leur chambre et et elle le
protège elle le protège il ya énormément
d'amour à la folie c'est une dévotion et
l'huile m oui merci où cette très belle
histoire et à très bientôt pour un
nouveau livre j'espère oui tout à fait
merci à vous merci nous avons suivi a
très vite
[Musique]